[Music]
this week on fyi 800 000 british
children have to take care of their
parents or siblings but a child care is
getting enough support i'm trying to
explain to different people what i've
been through in the morning and go haha
this looks to be you then doesn't it
[Music]
and while there's big changes ahead to
improve our education in england we
report on the children in ukraine and
afghanistan who can't even go to school
[Music]
this is fyi your weekly news show can
you believe it's been two years since
the uk's first lockdown was ordered and
we were all off school for months well
as nearly all kobe restrictions come to
an end in the uk we was all hoping we'd
see an enter kovid but cases are on the
rise again with 200 000 of us off school
because of it and some schools have even
had to partially close to try and
protect pupils and staff
so the government's education minister
nadim zahawi says he's determined to
help us all catch up and announce that
more help is going to be given to help
those of us who are behind in subjects
like english and maths from september
2023 all schools in england will have a
longer school day and have to open for a
minimum of 32.5 hours a week to get more
lesson time but the national association
of head teachers don't seem too happy
saying that most schools in england are
already open for that amount of time and
that simply adding 5 or 10 minutes to a
day is unlikely to bring much if any
benefit
not all of us may think it sometimes but
we're actually really lucky that we get
the chance to go to school
across the world loads of young people
can't and without an education they have
no way out of poverty at the chance to
get a decent job like in afghanistan
when the taliban ruled the country in
the 1990s girls were banned from getting
an education and since they seized back
power last year girls haven't been
allowed to go to secondary school only
primary school the taliban promised
girls would be allowed in education this
time but recently they've gone back on
their promise
some girls have taken to the streets to
protest while many have already fled the
country so they can get an education
we have to go because we didn't have any
other choice because
serving our country is just by edu
getting educated and of course there's a
lot of concern for kids in ukraine as
the war continues many aren't able to go
to school as always in fyi we like to
hear from young people and every week
we've been bringing you guys young
voices from ukraine
[Music]
anastasia is a student who decided to
stay put in her hometown in the west of
ukraine
right now though lessons have stopped
for her so instead of studying she's
helping in the war effort
today we were
collecting some humanitarian aid for our
refugees and also for our army right now
there are a lot of fights in cave
we
have already sent more than 25 buses
with humanitarian aid to cities all
around ukraine a lot of us feel really
tired because
we live in non-stop regime
this is our
camouflage
which our army can use
so it is the 13 day and i'm still in my
city i'm still in ukraine and we are
still sending buses to people who are
now in bomb shelters in different cities
who are the russian military is bombing
peaceful houses
right now i would like to say that i
don't feel really safe in my town on the
left of ukraine because just a few days
ago russia bombed a military base and
any day russian rockets may be here and
this is just reality ukrainians live in
so my studies have been stopped and in
my case i spent almost 24 hours per day
in our humanitarian aid headquarters and
so i don't know
when
it will be possible to
go back to just thermal lessons
lottie and henry are from the uk but
travel to the polish ukrainian border to
see first hand how their mother who
works for a charity is helping support
ukrainian refugees they met sasha who
fled from his home in the capital kiev
what do you miss most about ukraine
uh
everything i mean i miss i miss my house
i miss my friends but even like basic
stuff
like
i don't know my kitchen my room my bed
everything during covered 19 people
missed school but we knew that soon we'd
be back
how did it feel knowing that there's no
guaranteed time i'm a senior year at
high school so i'm graduating this year
and
it felt
really great at school this year because
well it was
more relaxed education wise i'm actually
sad that our final exams are being
declined because well i
i was preparing for them the whole year
before and yeah we do miss school and
not knowing what will happen next is it
just it kills me and what's your biggest
hope for ukraine
i hope that everyone will stay safe from
my friends my family and
all my fellow citizens and i just want
to return home
now our series of conversations that
gives us kids a voice about the big
issues is back it's conversation and
this week i meet crystal a young carer
who wanted to share her story
it's seven o'clock in the morning
a school day no chance of a lion
[Music]
wakey wakey darling
oh yeah
hey
movement let's go
and tell you what i'll meet you in there
because i'm gonna make your bed i open
your blinds yeah
just like the rest of us
fifteen-year-old crystal has got a lot
to do
but in her case that includes a whole
load of stuff that most of us never have
to worry about
[Music]
today i'm joining her to get just a
small taste of what life is like for her
[Music]
hello
hello
it's nice and warm
hi crystal hi do you want me to help you
with anything uh yes please um could you
move some of the teddy off the boat we
plead so i can put there okay
crystal is one of eight hundred thousand
children across the uk with caring
responsibilities
she looks after her sister jess who's
nine as well as helping her mum becky
and her dad kim who both have health
problems
do you find that like sometimes you
can't do things like with your friends
because you have to help your family
i felt like that imprimed me a little
bit but that was when i didn't really
know
much about being a young carer
when my mates asked if i couldn't come
over i go i'm so sorry i can't i'm
looking after jess or we've got like a
doctor's appointment and then go oh okay
we can sort something for the next week
and then so
they're quite understanding yeah
crystal's sister has a range of health
issues including autism she's a bundle
of energy but any change to her normal
routine can cause her extreme distress
luckily today's a good day and we're all
getting on really well
i love your pajamas they look so comfy
crystal's mum and dad also need support
her dad has a chronic lung condition
which sometimes makes it hard for him to
breathe thank you very much again
and her mom has been in and out of
hospital with stomach pains as well as
suffering from anxiety and depression
it means that crystal is always worried
about them
can do your fringe at 20 past eight
we're just about ready to leave the
house but it's not been easy
[Music]
and just before nine crystal arrives at
school where she's studying for her
gcses
today it's a welsh class one of her best
subjects
[Music]
but even at school her caring
responsibilities are never far from her
mind
do you ever find that when you're at
school you're just worrying so much
about them you can't focus and you feel
like you're not doing as well as you
could
certain days where mum was in hospital
and everyone was just shouting and
shouting and shouting i was like just
shut up and trying to concentrate and do
this as best as i can in west mountain
hospital you're always doing it for her
like trying to absolutely that's what i
was doing when i had mocks because when
she was in hospital i was like right i'm
doing this for mum whatsoever if i don't
get good grades and at least i tried
local councils are supposed to identify
and help people like crystal who are
young carers
but it's estimated only one in five of
them get any practical help
in a survey 93 of her teachers said more
needs to be done to help young carers
they said that caring responsibilities
means some children often miss school or
are late for lessons and they find it
hard to keep up with their work
and more than half of young carers said
they suffer with mental health issues
like anxiety stress or depression for
crystal one of the biggest challenges is
that not everyone understands what she
has to go through
it annoys me when people just take the
mic out of it because i'm trying to
explain to
different people
what i've been through in the morning
and go haha sucks to be you then doesn't
it
it's like
no it doesn't stick to me because i'm
quite proud of what i do actually thanks
sorry about
as the school day comes to an end
crystal arrives home
she tries to find some time to do her
maths revision but her sister is
desperate for her attention
she's so demanding honestly she'll come
home and first thing she'll go is
[ __ ] can you play like no
i can't i've got homework you should be
reading too
i demand you play um
stop shouting no look how far away we
are play no yes go away
oh what was that for when she's kicking
off we've got either lever to it because
mommy was just kicking off she can be
quite violent yeah she start kicking and
punching and sometimes biting
and so when she's like that we leave her
to it or we go just go in the room go
calm down yeah
eventually crystal gives up on her
homework to spend some time with her
sister and reassure her
[Music]
and once we're all friends again it's
time to help out with preparing the
dinner tonight it's a delicious pasta
bolognese
what did everyone think of it
squanderedly anxious
[Music]
it has been such a long day i'm
exhausted
i can't even imagine how difficult it
would be to do this every single day
crystal is so strong and resilient
despite all the challenges she has to
face
i'm off to bed now
[Music]
at the weekend crystal finally gets a
chance to have some fun
she's joined a young carers group so she
can meet other people in similar
situations to herself and get some
emotional support
the group gets to go on outings and take
part in activities
and today to escape from the challenges
at home we're heading to an escape room
[Music]
guys for it we haven't got the time to
be patient
wait wait that works
is it helpful to hang out and just know
that there are other teenagers in
similar situations to you we can always
be there for each other and it's just
nice to know what others are going
through and you're not the only one in
your own boat
[Music]
it's been so lovely meeting crystal and
her family
i thought she might resent the fact that
she's effectively had to grow up much
sooner than she would do normally
but actually that's not true at all
looking after her mum and dad and sister
jess is just what she does
it's not something she feels bitter
about
in fact she's fiercely protective of
them and she's proud that she can help i
think she's amazing
[Music]
well that was a really good report
scholar and crystal's so impressive
isn't she yes she really is well
remember if you want to see more about
what we've covered on this week's show
there's more conversations on big issues
that are really important to us and and
i don't get to explain it on the war in
ukraine on our webpage head to
first.news forward slash fyi
well like crystal's sister jess who has
autism we also heard from ben who lives
in the usa who also has autism when he
was 10 he wrote a poem called iron mod
about how it feels to have autism and
after sharing it online it went viral
smart world autism day ben's poem was
made into a song by a record company and
has already won awards we're gonna leave
you guys with a message from ben and his
music video see you next week hi fyi
thank you for helping spread autism
acceptance i hope that my poem and now
song video can help children who are
autistic learn that they are not alone
in feeling different and that being
different is a good thing
[Music]
you can do anything you wanna do
you may be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you